so hey but look man you've been doing
your thing for some years now yeah yeah
um obviously heavily MMG Affiliated I
just saw you uh with Ross would you have
dreads this past weekend when Drake was
there not this weekend I didn't go yeah
but that would have been the weekend to
go the waffle color guy was there as you
said in the freestyle yeah
man I ain't gonna I had just got back in
town from doing like
um like a four City trip four days four
days for um four days four flights so
yeah for you
um because you know you have a pretty
crazy life that you've lived
um you've been doing the rap [__] I feel
like
I first met you probably around 2010 or
11 when I was living out there
it's been a grind
um yeah yeah uh what motivates you to
still do this hip-hop [__] man because
you are like you you're a new artist but
you're also not you're a veteran in this
year for a long time
um basically like the progress you know
what I'm saying and then like if you
listen to my stuff from then to now you
know it's a huge they don't even sound
the same you know what I'm saying and
then um man I realize keeping me out of
a lot of trouble you know what I'm
saying so the progress and then you know
my son so you know he's looking at
everything I do right now too real heavy
so that's the last thing I want to do is
do some uh some [__] yeah yeah because
how was your son he's 15. oh yeah he's
old enough tonight yeah like he's
scoping anything you know what I'm
saying yeah because you obviously coming
up you did us what five years yeah yeah
Federal identify your family yeah how
old were you when that happened
um
20 21
something like that but yeah I did five
years uh Max fed prison what what what
what for
um distribution of weapons oh [__] yeah
that's a serious uh distribution weapons
got me on a domestic terrorist list so
you were like Nicholas Cage and the Lord
of War kind of
I don't know what was going on um me and
my homie was taking guns down to Arizona
and um trading them to the essays for uh
for cope right you know what I'm saying
so
I didn't know how big those dudes were
you know what I'm saying we were just
going down there getting it you know
what I'm saying bringing you didn't know
who like necessarily how I don't know
how I was rocking you know what I'm
saying so
um we were doing that and um you know
the Fed was on them I guess some dudes
was part of the cartel [__] yeah so you
just kind of caught astray well we went
down there to buy something and then one
day one of them was like hey can you
give me some of those and I was like
yeah because my homie had a gun on his
hip and uh he was like um you give me
that I give you this I was like what I
was like you give me that whole thing
you said yeah give me three of those I
get this whole thing so we left came
back
he gave it to us and then you know I
went and sold it to him I was like it
was the best money ever so of course we
started going back and forth doing that
you know dude was giving me a list
and uh of like what he needed yeah and
it started to get like it started to get
a little crazy after a while so I mean
everything happened for a reason so the
last time he gave me a list it was like
a grenade launcher on there and I was
like man I can't get that yeah where am
I gonna get that what do you need that
for he was like you can go ahead just
try yeah and I'm like all right but by
then you know what I'm saying like a
week later we ended up in cuffs Jesus
yeah that is one thing I mean I'm from
Arizona and there's always a very high
premium on Firepower because I feel like
they have they're always fighting Wars
yeah because we was going out to Tucson
that's where this was going on at yeah
the cartels every cartel is always at
War and they always need more weapons
man yeah it was crazy it was real crazy
damn so did they did those guys end up
getting knocked too yeah yeah they when
when they came and got those guys they
wrapped me up and um
you know I didn't know what's going on
or whatever so it was kind of like um
they knew what was up like you know the
feds ain't stupid you know what I'm
saying yesterday it was like okay this
dude what was that what was doing five
years like man was that something that
was like mentally I'm sure it was
mentally taxing something and it was a
it was a real eye-opener um
because I I did my time had a USP so I
was the only one in there that um
didn't have at least a 10 to 15 year
sentence you know what I'm saying so um
it was weird I had I actually had a um
an attempted murder warrant in Denver
called Colorado Springs so they had to
send me to a Max because I was high
custody so they sent me to a Max prison
I mean it was an eye-opener like out the
gate like it was it was totally
different world man it ain't nothing
like you see on the tick tocks and stuff
I do is be in prison playing around and
stuff like that it's like every day
serious yeah they say like Federal like
is federal prison nicer than a state
prison though if you go to uh FCI or um
a camp yeah but where you were at it was
no everybody in there had everybody in
there like my roommate had 35 years
Jesus yeah one of my dudes Peewee I used
to hang out with all the time he had 99
years for what
um my dude had 35 years for drugs Peewee
had robbed a couple banks
um but so everybody that had violence
anybody that had any violence in their
record they were at your spot Jesus man
like for you was it like uh like what
were the things that you had to kind of
like
do on a daily basis to kind of keep your
mind somewhere else you know because I'm
sure man I used to write every day I
used to rap just right yeah and then
like you know the homies are the car I
was with they used to like
man let me hear that let me hear that
you know what I'm saying it's like
hearing me rapping stuff like that but
other than that work out like crazy
and then um when I first got there it
was kind of
kind of a weird situation because I was
in a room with a dude from Mississippi
and you know my my homie was like man we
need to sell my homie actually took a
sale from him he's like you can't be in
this cell no more you know and I was
like Danny [__] right like this you know
what I'm saying this is crazy but that's
crazy so you uh you before you got
incarcerated were you dabbling with the
rap [__]
barely barely barely yeah would you say
that you're getting locked up made you
like own that a little bit more 100
because being in there you know
um even like um you know being in the
room with somebody who had 35 years you
know what I'm saying he got locked up at
18. right you know what I'm saying so
it makes you look at things a lot
different you know what I'm saying you
ain't in there with everybody I got two
three years you're gonna run into half
of these dudes on the street like I'd
say 95 of the people I was in prison
with will never see the streets again
crazy